President Trump is acquitted in the
Senate Mitt Romney votes to convict and
Joe Biden's long journey to nowhere
continues i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show aventure Piro show is
sponsored by expressvpn why haven't you
gotten a VPN yet visit expressvpn
dot-com /ban well it's over we're done
Hisle was that a giant waist up yep
pretty much turns out that entire
impeachment debacle was a giant waste of
time we spent an enormous amount of time
and energy covering something that
amounted to nothing the only person who
ended up crossing party lines to vote
against the president of his own party
was Mitt Romney of Utah we'll get to
Senator Romney in just one second but
suffice it to say President Trump
ends this thing in a better position
than he began this thing right now an
extraordinarily high percentage of
Americans according to Gallup are
positive about the economy some 63% of
Americans approve of president from
handling of the economy from Sapru Ville
rating is closing in on 50 percent for
the first time in his presidency the
Democrats look like they're in disarray
this did not do any heavy lifting for
them they didn't change broad American
perceptions of President Trump that was
all baked into the cake already as it
turns out they didn't change broad
American perceptions of Congress other
than the generalized belief that
Congress is useless and a partisan
institution designed to go after people
of the other party so nothing really
changed here and despite the attempts by
the media to turn Romney's vote into a
referendum on Republicans generally that
didn't change anything either because
again people kind of knew who Mitt
Romney was people knew kind of what Mitt
Romney was going to do here they sort of
see how MIT Romney perceives himself so
the media's attempts to turn that into a
big story are of course a giant fail
according to the New York Times after
five months of hearings investigations
and revelations about president Trump's
dealings with Ukraine I divided the
United States Senate acquitted him on
Wednesday of charges that he abused his
power and obstructed Congress to aid his
own reelection bringing an acrimonious
impeachment trial to his expected end
and a pair of votes whose outcome was
never in doubt the Senate fell well
short of the two-thirds margin that
would have been needed to remove the
45th president the verdicts came down
after three weeks of debate almost
entirely along party lines with every
Democrat voting guilty on both charges
and Republicans uniformly voting not
guilty on the obstruction of Congress
charged only one Republican senator
Romney of Utah broke with his party to
judge mr. Trump guilty of Abby
of power this is the third impeachment
trial of a president and the third
acquittal in American history
it ended the way it began with
Republicans and Democrats at odds and of
course that was never going to change
nothing really did change her all that
happened is that President Trump now
gets to go around holding up a newspaper
that says acquittal and here is the
thing here is the thing the expectation
that Democrats had I don't know what
what they thought they were gonna get
out of there okay so president from
shows up at the National Prayer
Breakfast this morning and he literally
is holding up a copy of USA Today with
the giant headline acquitted sort of
like Harry Truman in 1919 xlviii holding
up the headline Dewey defeats Truman and
is holding up all the headlines right
he's got the New York Times over there
in the Washington Post he's holding up
every newspaper he could find
saying Trump acquitted and in the minds
of the American public that means this
is over and basically no matter what
happens on the Ukraine score it's not
gonna matter anymore in the same way
that once the Mobil report came over
that didn't matter anymore so it looks
like they keep taking shots at him and
he looks Teflon the more shots you take
of the President of the United States
and the more that bounce off of him the
more it looks as though he is
impregnable impregnable as though he is
not damageable and that is clearly true
of President Trump right now that that
hasn't stopped the Democrats from trying
to claim that somehow they won a victory
here but they didn't they didn't it
turns out that when you take a shot at
the president this way and you miss that
it doesn't redound it to your benefit
and this certainly has not returned it
to the benefit of the Democrats we'll
get some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about your employees
you may have noticed that we started our
show a little bit later than usual today
and you may have been asking yourself
just why well let's say that you had a
very very important produce some of
you'll be working with for years really
terrific at his job and he just decides
to take a day off and it is the most
inconvenient day off in human history so
when the technology starts to go south
there's no one there to fix it let's
call this person Austin and let's say
that Austin just he wasn't there today
to make sure that everything ran now
it's not quite his fault I mean he had
planned on this day off but still but
still does a doctor get an emergency
phone call in the middle of the night
and show up at the hospital he does and
Austin didn't show up which means
perhaps it's time for us to start
looking at zip recruiter com zip
recruiter insures that the best possible
employees come in failures people who
will never take a day off zip recruiter
com
no wonder four out of five employers who
post on super career yet a quality
within a very first day because great
candidates are told to apply to your
jobs and then zip recruiter helps filter
them so you don't just get your inbox
filled with a bunch of garbage
candidates whenever you open up
applications for a candidacy for a job
opening well you know you may end up
with a bunch of not great applications
zip recruiter helps you go through all
of those make sure that you get only the
best applications zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire c-y zip recruiters
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at our web
addresses zip recruiter comm slash at
daily wire that is zip recruiter com /a
Dai ly WI re zip record comm slash daily
wire by the way Austin also happens to
be a Cubs fan another good reason for me
to take a look at zip recruiter comm
again that zip recruiter comm slash a
daily wired dia Dai ly w I re zip
recruiter dot-com okay so the the
Democrats keep it trying to claim that
they are not owned here here is here is
Justice Roberts yesterday declaring that
Trump was not guilty on the abuse of
power votes this was the historic moment
when it became obvious if it was not
already that Trump was not going
anywhere
here is Justice Roberts announcing the
result of the vote this article of
impeachment 48 senators have pronounced
Donald John Trump President of the
United States guilty as charged
52 senators have pronounced him not
guilty as charged
two-thirds of the Senators present not
having pronounced him guilty the senator
judges that the respondent Donald John
Trump President of the United States is
not guilty as charged
in the first article of impeachment okay
so that was the mo Democrats are still
trying to suggest that they won a
victory here so you have a couple of big
opinion pieces today one from Adam
Schiff Jerry Nadler Zoe Lofgren Hakeem
Jeffries Val Deming Sylvia Garcia and
Jason Crowe those would be the
Democratic House managers in the
impeachment trial of President Trump and
they wrote an opinion piece for The
Washington Post that is titled Trump
won't be vindicated the Senate won't be
either yeah what we're okay we're at the
drugstore or the drugstore I would sign
in Feld's jerk store remember this
episode where where Costanza gets in an
argument with a guy and then he comes up
with a great comeback but it is too late
it's now too late right he's left the
venue and so he waits like the entire
episode and then drops the comeback
randomly
this is the Democrats now they are now
in the jerk store episode of Seinfeld
according to these House Democratic
Managers over the past two weeks we have
argued the impeachment case against
President Trump presenting overwhelming
evidence that he solicited foreign
interference to cheat in the next
election and jeopardized our national
security by withholding hundreds of
millions of dollars in security
assistance to pressure Ukraine to do his
political bidding again if they thought
they had overwhelming evidence they
wouldn't have needed additional
witnesses so it's weird that they were
moaning about the need for additional
witnesses when the president got caught
and his scheme was exposed he tried to
cover it up and obstruct Congress's
investigation in an unprecedented
fashion again that is not true
as the trial progressed a growing number
of Republican senators acknowledged that
the house had proved the president's
serious misconduct no a growing number
of Republican senators acknowledged that
the president had done something wrong
but they did not believe that the house
had proved the accusations that they
brought to the fore in this impeachment
trial nonetheless the House Democrats
say throughout the trial new and
incriminating evidence against the
president came to light almost daily and
there can be no doubt it will continue
to emerge in books and newspapers in
congressional hearings most important
reports of former national security
adviser John Putin's forthcoming book
only further confirm that the president
illegally withheld military aid to
Ukraine until Kiev announced the sham
investigations that the president sought
for his political benefit although
Bolton told the house he'd rather sue
then appeared to testify pursuant to a
subpoena he appeared to have a change of
heart and made it clear he would be
willing to testify in the Senate that's
not accurate either basically he said
I'll testify but it was unclear that
Putin was ever going to violate
executive privilege apps in some sort of
court order now what they're saying here
is not entirely false in the sense that
it's quite possible that they then call
Bolton in the house he says something
damaging the Republican senators look
bad it's one of the reasons why I was
not completely sanguine on the idea of
no more witnesses I thought okay maybe
the best thing to do here is have two
weeks of witnesses get this all behind
us and then the Democrats have no more
bullets in their gun right all the ammo
has been spent so we'll see if this
materializes or not but I will say that
after the acquittal is over the American
people I think are just breathing a sigh
and being okay that's another thing we
don't have to worry about now because
honestly this thing was just a pain in
the butt notwithstanding the
Constitution's mandates say the
Democrats that the Senate shall have the
sole power to try impeachments a narrow
majority of senators opted not to and
instead acted as though it were an
appellate court precluded from going
beyond the record in the house
nothing supported this unprecedented
prohibition on witnesses and documents
except the overriding interest of a
president determined to hide any further
incriminating in
from the American people and a Senate
majority leader in his thrall you're
right the Senate was not prohibited from
calling witnesses but the Senate is not
obligated to call witnesses either this
is why the Senate gets to preside over
the rules of the trial and if you don't
have a majority you don't really get to
about the fact that you don't have
a majority in the Senate when it comes
to obviously constitutional procedures
and then the Democrats suggest that this
means that President Trump is basically
going to cheat in 2020 no matter what
and as per the usual arrangement the
Democrats then it decide that there is
only one hero one hero of the day and
that of course is mittens Mitt Romney
the senator from Utah and the house
Democratic managers say when we made our
final arguments to the Senate we asked
whether there was one Republican senator
who would say enough do impartial
justice as their oath required and
convict the President and there was Mitt
Romney the senator from Utah showed a
level of moral courage that validated
the founders faith that we were up to
the rigors of self-governance now this
stuff I'm not willing to hear from
Democrats I'm not now here's my
perspective on Romney so first here's
what Mitt Romney had to say and
announcing that he was going to vote to
convict President Trump the senator from
Utah and of course 2012 Republican
nominee for president of the United
States who got shellacked by Barack
Obama here's Mitt Romney announcing his
votes came to trump the grave question
the Constitution tasks senators to
answer is whether the president
committed an act so extreme and
egregious that it rises to the level of
a high crime and misdemeanor yes he did
the president asked a foreign government
to investigate his political rival the
president withheld vital military funds
from that government to press it to do
so the president delayed funds for an
American ally at war with Russian
invaders the president's purpose was
personal and political accordingly the
president is guilty of an appalling
abuse of public trust okay and then
Romney defended this on Fox News he
suggested that it was hard to imagine a
more destructive attack on the
Constitution he had sort of a media
rollout of his vote it was pretty
obvious apparently to people inside the
Senate this is the way the Romney's been
going over the last week or so so here
is Romney I believe that the act he took
an effort to corrupt an election
is as destructive an attack on the oath
of office and our Constitution as I can
imagine it is a high crime and
misdemeanor within the meaning of the
Constitution and that is not a decision
I take lightly
it is the last decision I wanted to take
the personal consequences the political
consequences that fall on me as a result
of that are going to be extraordinary
but I swore an oath before God and I'm a
religious person that I would apply
impartial justice and applying impartial
justice said what the President did was
grievously wronged ok so I think the
Mitt Romney is getting this wrong
right I've said this all along I think
the Mitt Romney is is not calibrating
his his verdict correctly I understand
why he is doing what he is doing I do I
mean I'm not gonna sit here and pretend
that President Trump made a perfect
phone call I'm not gonna sit her and
pretend the president Trump did nothing
wrong with regard to Ukraine I think
that senator Lamar Alexander's threat on
why he was voting for acquittal and why
he was voting for no new witnesses was
basically correct Lamar Alexander said
that the president did something wrong
but it doesn't amount to an impeachable
offense mainly because the president
didn't show that he had the motive to
simply skew the election in 2022 that's
what this is all about as opposed to
thin-skinned nonsense about 2016 which
is really a much more plausible theory
of what exactly trump was into with
regard to Ukraine I can see how Romney
would come to this conclusion I think
the conclusion is wrong I think that all
the other Republicans agree that this
conclusion is wrong so a couple of
things I think everybody is wrong that
Romney first of all I don't buy into the
theory that Mitt Romney is some sort of
ridiculous charlatan who is simply in it
for the walls he's simply in it because
he wants the strange new respect of the
media that's not the impression that I
get of Romney as a human being I don't
think that Mitt Romney is somebody who
was who is simply doing this for the
thrill of the thing I think that he felt
that he had taken an oath of office and
that as he analyzed the evidence this is
the side he came down on and that's his
prerogative
he's an independently elected senator
from Utah I think he's wrong I think
he's wrong I think he's dead wrong but
do I think that it is his responsibility
to adjudicate whether his opinion is
going to impact Trump or impact 20/20 or
any of the rest that's not his job in
this particular arena his job is to
decide whether this rose of level of
high crimes and misdemeanors which is
why when Senator Rubio's
that sure this was kind of a high crime
and misdemeanor but I'm gonna vote for
acquittal anyway because there's an
election coming up in 11 months well
that that is actually not the function
of the Senate so Romney independently
adjudicating how he felt about this I'm
not gonna come down on Romney for that
I'll come down on him for his judgment
I think his judgment is incorrect but
the the hit on him from the right which
is that he's a Chuck he's a traitor
he's the worst I just I don't buy it
right Donald Trump jr. did a little bit
of this yesterday he tweeted out that he
wanted Romney expelled from the caucus
said MIT Romney is forever bitter he
will never be President he was too weak
to beat the Democrats then so he's
joining them now he's now officially a
member of the resistance and should be
expelled from the GOP okay first of all
the GOP doesn't expel people second of
all the this notion that Romney is
sitting there and he's super bitter that
he's not Secretary of State or something
I I have serious doubts about that again
assuming the worst of intentions from
Romney in a situation where I really
don't think the evidence justifies that
is a bad look for Republicans and it's
silly on the other hand I'm not willing
to hear from House Democrats that Mitt
Romney is a man of courage that I'm not
willing to hear in the slightest and not
willing to hear that at all why well the
reason that Mitt Romney is not president
and Donald Trump is is because the media
savaged him as Donald Trump in 2012 made
the media and the Democrats the same
people who today are praising him
praising him to the skies all brave Oh
Mitt Romney he's the greatest he's the
best five seconds ago I'm old enough to
remember five seconds ago you guys were
declaring that he was a racist who put
dogs on the top of his car was gonna put
black people back in Chains want to
shove women into binders and that he was
a horrible one percenter who disdained
the poor who fired people so they would
lose their health care plan and their
wives would die of cancer the Mitt
Romney was a brutal homophobe would
forcibly cut the hair of gay kids back
in the 1950s hey you painted Mitt Romney
the most milquetoast human being who has
ever watched the planet perhaps the most
bland human being who has ever walked
the planet but at least in his in his
life a very upright citizen you painted
him as the worst person ever to walk the
earth and then Republicans were like
okay you're gonna paint anybody that way
well yeah how about Trump take this okay
so I'm not gonna hear from Democrats
what a wonderful virtuous upstanding
citizen Mitt Romney is now that he has
done something you like he didn't change
you are just a bunch of opportunistic
a-holes
I mean that's what's happening here it's
like this I'm not willing to hear so on
the right I'm not
to hear that Mitt Romney who I think we
all basically agreed in 2012 was a good
guy and that even if you disagreed with
his politics even if you thought that he
was vacillating on key issues like
abortion over the course of his career
even if you thought that he like I wrote
a column in 2008 why MIT Romney should
not be the nominee and then I wrote one
again in 2012 why he should not be the
nominee okay I actually didn't favor
Romney as the nominee in 2012 when he
won the nomination but it was pretty
obvious that Mitt Romney is not a bad
man or that he isn't motivated by the
desire for MSNBC love okay so I'm not
gonna hear that from the right and on
the left I'm not gonna hear you guys
champion him as a hero because honestly
go screw yourselves yeah you're
ridiculous and when I hear MSNBC sharing
Mitt Romney you can you can just you can
shove it all you people in 2012 you're
declaring him the worst person on earth
so your beloved Barack Obama would
retain the presidency despite the fact
it was a garbage president and now you
owe Mitt Romney Oh Mitt Romney anybody
who falls for the strange and respect
line from the Democrats is a fool or a
or or just deeply disingenuous
because guess what these strange due
respect lasts for approximately as long
as they don't realize that Mitt Romney's
gonna vote with Trump on 95% of issues
which by the way is a fact
okay the strange in respect for Jeff
Flake was based on the fact that he was
meaning to Trump they said nasty things
about Trump Jeff Flake voted with Trump
most of the time and if he had continued
on in the Senate voting with Trump he
wouldn't have gotten they they wouldn't
have said that his votes in favor of
bills that Trump sponsored or now
principled votes that it was the same
principled man standing up to Trump and
voting for a thing because the way it
works for the media is when you agree
with them you're a good noble human
being and when you disagree with them
then you're a bad evil human being so
MIT Romney agrees with them on
impeachment now he's a hero of the
republic five seconds ago he was the
worst person ever to walk the earth and
must never be President of the United
States and was a ridiculous fool to boot
but here as MSNBC praising Romney to the
skies because they're a bunch of liars
MIT Romney of course the former
Republican nominee in the moment as he
was speaking it felt historic indeed it
will cement senator Romney's legacy and
stain what the White House was no doubt
hoping would be a clean party-line
acquittal today to spark the part this
might the party's refusal to hear from
witnesses or admit new documents into
evidence
Democrats are taking pains to draw a
distinction likely to become a refrain
in the coming weeks and months that
today's acquittal does not equal an
exoneration for the president who will
remain impeached forever okay and again
is it listen that media coverage Brian
Williams and when he's not flying fake
helicopters over a rock being shot down
by the by the insurgents they I'm sorry
that this whole thing is ridiculous just
doing the bidding of the Democrats well
he was he was acquitted but he wasn't
exonerated yes but an acquittal is never
an exoneration isn't that that's how
what acquittals do I mean that's what
trials are trials are not exonerations
trials are acquittals like by their very
nature we'll get some more of this in
just one second
and by the way it just demonstrates that
Trump is winning the fact that everybody
is is acting as they are acting right
now we'll get to that in just one moment
first two out of three dudes are going
to experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are 35 it runs
in my family and there is a reason that
I have been using it keeps because I
look at my father I love my father I
don't want my hair to look like my
father's hair when I am his age or even
when he was in his 40s here's the good
news with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help keep help you keep the
hair you have a half the cost of your
local pharmacy keeps treatments start at
just 10 bucks a month plus for a limited
time you can get your first month for
free prevention is key keeps treatments
really do work they're up to 90 percent
effective that reducing and stopping for
their hair loss the sooner you start
using keeps the more hair you'll save so
act fast many men even experience hair
regrowth with keeps treatment keeps has
revolutionized the way men are treated
for hair loss because thanks to heaps
you no longer have to wait at the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription instead you can visit a
doctor online get your hair loss
medication delivered to your home
directly if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps calm /
Ben to receive your first month of
treatment for free it really is super
simple it's easy it's a lot cheaper I
know because I've been using
keeps that is a ke PS calm / Ben keeps
calm / Ben you may not be losing your
hair right now guys but I promise you
you will be spoon so go check out keeps
calm / Ben right now now again do I
think that Mitt Romney did anything that
is morally bereft here no I don't
because I don't think that is the
responsibility of the United States
Senator to be looking along the spectrum
of oh no Democrats are gonna use what I
say against the present that's not his
job here so I think that he was
in his judgment absolutely this is why I
think that both the media response and
the Republican response here are pretty
ridiculous and when I say pretty
ridiculous I mean supremely ridiculously
Elizabeth Warren out there praising that
Romney is just ridiculous a--the Warren
who hates Romney right me let's be real
about this Elizabeth Warren thinks that
Romney's a skunk
I was with Warren is is a despicable
human being and here she is with
lawrence o'donnell both of whom hate
romney but now they love romney now
Romney's the best strange no respect
pouring from the heavens what was it
like listening to that one Republican
stand up and see this case basically the
same way you do I thought I was
listening to a decent and honorable man
oh shut up and did the right thing he
was decent and honorable man except when
he voted for you know like justice
Cavanaugh and then and then he was bad
man but now he's a decent and honorable
man meanwhile you know the White House
is is pursuing a stupid strategy with
regard to Romney what here's what they
should do they should just say listen
Mitt Romney is entitled to his own
judgment right now Mitt Romney is
entitled to his own take on this issue
the president has been acquitted 52
other senators disagreed with him in his
own party his logic obviously didn't
agree with theirs but he's the United
States Senator have a nice day that
should be it because the bottom line is
you still have that picture up from
holding up the big acquitted sign and
the acquitted sign is the only thing
that matters the media want to play up
the conflict between Romney and Trump
and set this thing up as true hero of
the Republic Mitt Romney versus Donald
Trump instead Trump should just defuse
that and be like okay fine Romney has
the view I have my view obviously I win
right you can afford to be magnanimous
in victory instead because magnanimity
is not in the cards for the White House
they release Trump tweeted out a video
montage bashing Romney which of course
like what is the point of this seriously
what is the point of this here he is
doing this like slippery stealthy Mitt
Romney had us fooled
being in Donald Trump's magnificent
hotel and having his endorsement is a
delight posing his Republican he tried
to infiltrate trump's administration as
Secretary
now his cover's blown exposed by news
reports as a Democrats secret asset
Barack Obama will be reelected president
Mitt Romney's a Democrat secret assets
he's a secret asset he's the senator
from Utah which is maybe the reddest
state in America and truly just
ridiculous this is ridiculous on all
sides and again I'm not gonna take it
from the media who suggest that that
Romney is now great hero of the Republic
when they hated him five seconds ago I'm
not gonna take it from Republicans who
voted for Romney five seconds ago
Ronna Romney McDaniel who was forced to
change her last name basically the Trump
points in order to be the head of the
RNC she tweeted out this is not the
first time I have disagreed with mitt
and I imagine it will not be the last
the bottom line is President Trump did
nothing wrong and the Republican Party's
more United than ever behind him I along
with the GOP stand with President Trump
okay again like whatever whatever okay
so here is the here is where we now sit
here's where we now sit and here's where
the president's head should be as
opposed to in Romney land which is where
the media would like it to me the
president wins he wins and this is why
the appropriate attitude I don't think
should be saying it out loud because
again I think that it the the Trump that
you like best is the Trump you see
during State of the Union you know
considered a Trump contained at Trump
he's like nuclear power II want to have
some pretty heavy cement shielding
around the around the nuclear power that
is generating all of the energy but
Twitter is is the nuclear League the
president tweeted out that he would be
president for life just to troll the
Democrats which is kind of Alamut it's
hilarious okay may not be good politics
but it is really funny he tweeted again
this graphic that he had tweeted before
show it was a cover of Time magazine
that shows Trump 20:28 from 2032 Trump
third all the way til Trump 2048 at
which point the President of the United
States would be let's see he is 73 years
old right and then it has Trump 2056 it
starts moving Trump 2060 Trump 2064
there'll be 150 years old and the
Democrats online they were going crazy
over this they're like he means that
he's really gonna be President forever
not unless his disembodied head is gonna
be President of the United States in
9,000 in 60,000 in forever like it's a
ridiculously they're really doing
like this means he's never gonna leave
office he's gonna declare himself
dictator he's going to like Darth
Sidious defeat the power of death and
hook himself up to machines I'll be the
disembodied floating ahead of Larry King
from Futurama or alternatively he's
trolling you guys in your idiot which i
think is much more likely alrighty we
were gonna get two more with regard to
the Democrats attempt to buy back a
victory from MP from plus we have to get
to the 2020 Democrats the reason they're
focused in on impeachment still even
after this thing is over is they're
looking at their field and they are in a
state of sheer absolute unbridled panic
and they definitely definitely should be
I'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact you've
got some big events coming up this year
right and that means that you want your
teeth to look good for all the pictures
but unfortunately you flushed your
retainers down the toilet when you were
15 and now your teeth have slid out of
place imperceptibly but then gradually
over time it started with kind of bad
and now you need to straighten those
teeth now what should you do should you
go get braces again no you're not a
teenager and how much fun is it to get
the food dunk stuck in there I gotta use
the water pick good times instead why
don't you just go get some clear
aligners from candid unlike braces
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable totally invisible you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing a thing plus you never have to
set foot in a doctor's office or a
waiting room your treatment is
prescribed remotely by licensed
orthodontist and candidate will deliver
everything you need directly to your
door unlike other companies candid only
works with orthodontist never general
dentists which means your treatment will
be designed by an expert in tooth with
20 years of experience on average if
you're looking ahead to wedding season
or a special event with candid the
average treatment is just six months and
you'll start seeing results way before
then learn more about canidates process
get a complimentary 3d scan of your
teeth and a candid studio near you it is
the simplest freest way to get started
for a limited time you can get started
with seventy five bucks off by using
Coach Shapiro at candid co.com slash
Shapiro that is candid co.com slash
appeal again use coach Shapiro for
seventy five bucks off candid co.com
slash apparel use code Shapiro so as I
say the Democrats are are in a state of
of sheer disarray because this has all
gone wrong for them the Iowa caucuses it
turns out as we'll get to in a second or
a complete and utter cluster F the the
race now looks like it is moving solidly
in the direction of Bernie Sanders
because whereas before it looked like
the field on the progressive side was
split between Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders it turns out that Ann
is increasingly consolidating the
Progressive Socialist wing of the
Democratic Party and there are serious
splits in the non socialist wing of the
Democratic Party between Biden and
Bloomberg and Amy Klobuchar and Peabody
Judge there are too many candidates in
that Lane right now which is precisely
the opposite of where that candidacy was
five seconds ago so that's a very
dangerous place for the Democrats to be
so instead the Democrats are trying to
cling to the last vestige of but we did
we impeached him we did we impeached him
really like we did and so they've
trotting out Chuck Schumer suggesting
that instead of conviction we got
durscher witzy and arguments he wasn't
actually acquitted he wasn't actually
acquitted he's still he's still
impeached guys he still is
come on instead of maintaining the
president's innocence the president's
counsel ultimately told the Senate that
even if the president did what he was
accused of it's not impeachable this has
taken the form of an escalating series
of durscher whit seein arguments
including quote abuse of power is not an
impeachable offense quote the president
can't be impeached for non criminal
conduct but he also can't be indicted
for criminal conduct quote if a
president believes his own reelection is
essential to the nation then a quid pro
quo is not corruption none of this makes
any difference this is just the
Democrats shouting at the sky because
they didn't get what they want instead
you have Joe Biden out there on the
stump mumbling to himself about how
Trump shouldn't view acquittal as a
victory there's only one problem any
time the president surpasses an
expectation is the dirty secret of
politics it's something Bill Clinton was
really good at Bill Clinton would
deliberately set low expectations just
so that he could surpass them well the
expectations for Trump are so low that
when he surpasses them it's great for
him so if the expectation that the
Democrats built up is that Trump would
be exiting office and then Trump is
acquitted that's a big win for him but
Biden says Trump shouldn't view
acquittal as a victory he shouldn't and
then Biden basically keels over he's
already calling it he says it's a
victory on the impeachment hoax on
Twitter is this a victory for the
president I can't imagine being
President on States and having all
one party plus someone from your own
party to vote to say you should be
thrown out of office and view that as a
victory also where am I in and why and
why again the Democratic attempts to buy
a victory from the from the ashes of
defeat that graphics the only one that
matters Donald Trump holding up that
newspaper that says acquitted that is
the only one that matters it this
morning instead he gets sherrod Brown
the Democratic senator from Ohio writing
in The New York Times in private
Republicans admit they acquitted Trump
out of fear out of fear so now it's all
about the Democratic senators who are
fearful of Trump and that is why they
voted the way that they did so Mitt
Romney is the only man of honor in the
Senate only because he happened to vote
alongside the Democrats and again the
Democrats are banking still on
impeachment despite the fact that it's a
failure out of the simple calculation
that the more they talk about their own
candidates the more trouble they have
Iowa continues to be just a complete
disaster area
so the results are still trickling in
from Iowa basically the results show
that Bernie won the most votes but that
Peabody Judge walks away with the most
delegates or at least even in the
delegate count people to judge is
getting a bump in New Hampshire from all
of that now there are reports that one
of the reasons that the Iowa caucuses
failed and the Democrats are now
trotting in this one out is that on a on
a 4chan board people had posted the
number of the DNC hotline for reporting
the precinct results and they clogged
the lines and so this supposedly twisted
everything there's only one problem
which the DNC itself has said that there
weren't significant problems in in this
particular area that the problem with
the app was just a problem with the app
if there is no real doubt about the
election results they want to blame it
on Republicans in some way they want to
blame it on trolls in some way but this
was pure unbridled stupidity because if
you don't protect yourself in the middle
of an election then I honestly don't
know how you can expect the American
people to trust you running virtually
anything right I mean it's very
difficult to imagine how we are supposed
to hand over our health care to people
who can't run an election involving
170,000 voters
Iowa has released some results they're
still not up to a hundred percent of
results and then they started releasing
minor Corrections last night they said
there will be minor Corrections to the
last batch of results we will be pushing
an update momentarily there was an error
that apparently confused votes for
Bernie Sanders for votes for Deval
Patrick pretty obvious that nobody voted
for Duval Patrick but the continuing
Fiasco in Iowa has robbed Bernie Sanders
of any momentum that he was going to get
from Iowa Peabody
however is getting a fairly large bump
in the in the New Hampshire primary and
that is horrible horrible news for Joe
Biden because right now as I say the
Democratic non Bernie Layne is seriously
divided and that is a huge problem
Elizabeth Warren is fading and she's
fading badly and she will likely be out
of the race by the time we hit South
Carolina if she finishes low in New
Hampshire which is a state that she
really needs to finish top two then
she's toast because really she think
she's gonna have more momentum and like
Nevada that's not a place where she's
ordinance Ouse Carolina where black
voters make a huge difference over half
of the Democratic base in South Carolina
voting in the primaries is black that's
Biden territory so we're gonna get to
more analysis of the Democratic field
burnt you can tell the front-runner is
because it's the person who's not on the
campaign trail
so Bernie's now playing it safe right
Bernie is not making a lot of public
appearances he's not doing a lot of
interviews he's just tweeting stupid
platitudes from his Twitter accounts and
the cheers of the moronic throng is to
populate that dumb website we'll get to
that in just one second first time for a
great Valentine's Day gift okay what is
the best Valentine's Day gift you know
you know what a great Valentine's Day
gift looks like it looks like fantastic
fantastic flowers but not all rose
bouquets are created equal so if you are
looking for roses that are guaranteed to
impress head to my friends at 1-800
flowers dot-com 1-800 flowers are some
of the freshest top-quality roses for
prices you will not believe take care of
all your rose needs today with the
official florist of Valentines 1-800
flowers there's nothing worse than going
and buying a bouquet of flowers and
handing it to your wife and within three
hours the thing is wilted that is not
what happens when you get a 1-800
flowers okay I know because every time I
go on the road I order flowers for my
wife I'm just that kind of husband but
you can be just that kind of human being
by getting a great bouquet from 1-800
flowers right now when you order early
you get 18 red roses for $29.99 or
upgrade to 24 red roses for 10 bucks
more which is a fantastic fantastic deal
they send these things to you overnight
they are there shipped overnight to
ensure freshness that are picked at
their peak so they are quite beautiful
and they last a long time in really
bouquet prices will be going up soon and
take advantage today 18 red roses for
$29.99 or an upgrade to 24 red roses for
10 bucks more it's an amazing offer but
it does expire today pick your delivery
date let 1-800 flowers handle the rest
when it comes to impressing her on
Valentine's Day trust in the Rose
authority to order 18 red roses for
$29.99 or upgrade to 24 red roses
for only 10 bucks more go to 1-800
flowers calm / appear oh that is 1-800
flowers calm / Shapira okay we're gonna
bring you the latest on the Democratic
race the panic is setting in and it is
obvious that the panic is setting in for
the Democrats we are going to get to
more of that momentarily first quick
note back in July last year I told you
about an amazing podcast called Apollo
11 what we saw hosted by my friend Bill
Whittle the show took you back in time
to the experience of living through the
Space Age beautifully produced right
here by a lot of folks at the daily
where well now bill has a new season of
the show this time it bill takes you
back to the Cold War the story is
incredibly well told the setting is
brilliantly descriptive you get a sense
of what it was like to live through
major events like the Berlin Airlift and
the Korean War the Cuban Missile Crisis
and the space race these milestones are
tied together to give you a sense of the
big picture the apocalypse that never
happened as the host bill does have a
tremendous way of pulling you in making
the story engaging entertaining whether
you remember living through some of
these events are like me you weren't
born yet they've already released two
episodes of this 12 part series you
should have something to catch up on
you should go listen now it has never
been more relevant than this year where
the left is going full-blown Comi in so
many of their policies in their language
Bernie Sanders this podcast emphasizes
the battle not only for capitalism but
for civilization itself the difference
in values between the west and the USSR
just go to daily wire.com slash Cold War
and start listening to this incredibly
important story it's really really
beautifully told that is daily wire comm
slash of Cold War or you can also get
the podcast over at iTunes and
SoundCloud and all the other places that
we do podcast also gang if you haven't
noticed already 20/20 its wild man this
is wild I've already finished an
impeachment we had the the killing of
Sam soleimani we had the Iowa caucuses
absolute failure we had the State of the
Union it's getting crazy and this is
just the beginning the best way to stay
informed go become a daily wire member
and get comprehensive news and info from
us on demand so we are giving you 20%
off all new memberships yep 20% off all
new memberships when using promo code DW
2020 members get our articles add free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
Ben Shapiro show selected bonus content
access to the mailbag and now my
election insight op-eds
plus our new all-access tier gets you
into live online Q&A discussions with me
Andrew Clayton Matt Walsh Michael moles
plus our site's writers and special
guests let us answer those questions for
you help you stay one step ahead of the
left if you haven't done so already
please go download our daily wire a
peanut push notifications for breaking
news
and special coverage is a really awesome
feature by the way the Sunday special
will be arriving back in your inbox soon
again that's promo code DW 2020 for 20%
off join today stay informed on all
things 2020 related we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as I say the Democrats are in a state
of sheer panic because they're supposed
frontrunner Joe Biden is in a state of
absolute collapse and he's basically
admitting as much Iowa was a bad showing
for him he ended up at something like 16
% of the votes compared to Pete Budaj
edge at 27% and Bernie Sanders at 26% in
terms of the delegate count that's a bad
showing he finished fourth ready
finished behind Elizabeth Warren - that
is not where you want to be the Rubio
strategy from 2016 it turns out third
third third third third third fourth
third first third third fourth it turns
out you don't win the nomination that is
not a way to win the nomination at some
point gonna have to win something which
is why the biggest thing on the calendar
right now for Joe Biden is Nevada and we
have no polling data from Nevada as in
none zero zip zilch last poll taken in
Nevada was USA Today Suffolk January
11th and it had Biden up one over Bernie
Sanders that ain't gonna cut it if Biden
loses the first three and Sanders wins
the first three then he's in real
trouble now he got a bit of a reprieve
because the Iowa caucus has ended up
being a bleep show but by the same token
if he finishes fourth in in New
Hampshire and now he's finished fourth
in the first two states if he does not
win Nevada outright he's toast because
all the momentum is gone he doesn't have
a large bankroll he doesn't have
momentum he's not somebody who's
inspiring
he was the default anti-trump candidate
and then Bernie came along and it turns
out that with a solid core of 25% is
Donald Trump found out you can win
primaries that way you can because
everybody else will split there are too
many candidates in these races well the
New Hampshire presidential primaries a
few weeks ago the polling showed that
Biden was running up close to Sanders
right that he was in first or second
place in all of the polling virtually
all of the polling that that budda judge
Warren had started to slide a little bit
after Iowa there are two new polls out
there is one from Emerson that poll
shows Bernie Sanders up 31 21 over Budaj
edge with Biden and Warren down at 12 so
there's a solid shot that he gets
shellacked in New Hampshire there's
another pullout from the Boston Globe at
Suffolk and it has again Budi judge
jumping by Sanders at 25 Buddha judge at
19 Biden at 12 and Warren at 11 so these
polls are consistent in showing a
massive collapse for Joe Biden in New
Hampshire which is a very very bad look
as a lap underwrite silver
err today he would have been okay
finishing seconds in Iowa to Bernie he
would have even been okay ish finishing
third behind Bernie and Warren either
result would have set Biden up to
deliver this sales pitch to the rest of
the Democratic electorate you now have a
clear choice between pragmatism and
socialism but to an electability and
purity I'm the only electable pragmatist
left in town choose but finishing behind
Budaj edge deprives him of that argument
and by the way finishing equal to
Klobuchar deprives him of that argument
which is why people from Biden's
campaign are basically going well what
if we just pretend the Iowa results are
illegitimate what do we pretend by
nationally like that okay in Iowa so
there's even a split inside the Biden
campaign just chaos over there
Symone Sanders campaign surrogate for
Joe Biden she was on the National TVs
and she was asked if the Iowa results
are legitimate and she refused to answer
the question yesterday your coms
director Kate Bedingfield was raising
concerns about the legitimacy of the
results is that a concern you still have
look I stand by Kate Bedingfield's
comments and I would also underscore
that the integrity of this process is
very important the results that Brianna
what I'm saying is that the results that
we have seen our partial results we do
not have all the data
okay so again she refuses has said the
results are legitimate but she does say
that we don't have all the data so
they're trying to throw aspirins and I
okay fine even take Iowa off the table
Biden needs to do better in New
Hampshire doesn't it I mean at least he
has to show some signs of life the great
suspicion of Joe Biden is that he's
actually a dead human being that he's
not actually alive so Joe Biden
basically admitted as much yesterday he
said listen we took a gut punch in Iowa
24 hours later they're still trying to
figure out what happened
at this rate New Hampshire will be the
first in the country to get away I am
NOT gonna sugarcoat it we took a gut
punch in Iowa the whole process took a
gut punch okay and then tries to buy it
back by saying that the process took a
gut punch but really he knows that his
campaign took a gut punch in Iowa and
this has led Biden to go on attack which
is a bad sign for Biden right he thought
he was just gonna float right over these
primaries this is the point where Joe
Biden is count dooku
in Revenge of the Sith and he is looking
over at Barack Obama and Barack Obama is
giving the thumbs down so that Anakin
can behead him I mean this is that's
what's going on right now he's looking
over and he's like why aren't you
helping me I'm y'all sit the Prentice
and Barack Obama's like no you just
thought you and akin finish him I mean
that that's that's truly what's going on
here there's only one person who can
save Joe Biden and that guy is out
golfing somewhere right that guy has no
interest in say he's Rorschach he's
looks down on Joe Biden and he says no
and so this has led Joe Biden to go on
attack he's now attacking both people to
judge and Bernie Sanders he's saying
that either would be a risk because Pete
is the mayor of in town of a hundred
thousand people how is that guy gonna be
a winner in a national election and
Bernie Sanders is a socialist these are
the choices that you are choosing now
again this is a same case but the
problem is that being default candidate
has rarely worked being default
candidate is usually likely to fail the
only time that I can remember default
candidates sort of walking away with it
was Mitt Romney and that was after
everybody tried everybody else but in
any case here is here is Joe Biden going
hard after his political opponents but a
senator Sanders is a nominee for the
party every Democrat in America up and
down the balon blue states red states
purple states
seesee in the easy districts and
competitive ones every Democrat will
have to carry the label senator Sanders
has chose for himself chosen for himself
he calls him and I don't criticize him
he calls himself a Democratic Socialist
is he really saying that obama-biden
administration was a failure Pete just
say it out loud I've great respect for
mayor Pete and a service of this nation
but I do believe it's a risk to be just
straight up with you for this party to
nominate someone who's never held by
office higher than mayor of a town of a
hundred thousand people in Indiana yeah
and then of course it's true and it's
amazing to me that he's waited this long
to say it and then nobody else has said
it this is what happens when you touch
all of your rivals all throughout the
campaign eventually you're forced to
attack them and now it looks like a
desperate attack because you are
starting to lose momentum here's the
bottom line for Biden Biden doesn't know
what his brand is because he doesn't
have a brand and so he keeps trying to
brand himself he said yesterday they
call him middle-class Joe who the hell's
ivory called the middle-class Joe's
everybody in the Senate just walked by
mama look they're close middle class
show what a failing campaign I mean he
feels like Jeb Bush circa 2016 I mean it
really is pretty brutal for Biden I
talked about the working poor all the
time I know they call me middle-class
Joe because they think middle-class Joe
because I'm concerned about the middle
class and the reason I'm concerned about
mom class is to find an avenue to get to
the middle class to be able to stay in
the middle class and when the middle
class does well everybody is a shot
people have a way up and in fact the
wealthy do very well I'm sorry was he
talking I sort of fell asleep there
anything everybody else fell asleep too
meanwhile speaking of desperate
candidates Elizabeth Warren trying to
recapture the magic that she had six
months ago but the magic is gone and so
she's trying to play the woman card
because she is one of the only
frontrunners who has a lady who has the
lady parts so here is Elizabeth Warren
explaining that if you don't vote for me
it's because you're a sexist okay this
didn't work for Hillary Clinton it's not
gonna work for Elizabeth Warren
especially since six months ago she was
leading in the primaries so here she is
doing the I am woman hear me squeak as a
woman studying politics here at st.
Anselm
I sometimes feel as if I will be at a
disadvantage when I enter the workforce
since a majority of people associate
politics with men do you believe that
the men in this race have a better
chance of beating Trump solely because
of their gender
I believe they think so but they'd be
wrong in the it's teach she said
tiresome okay so she's toast she's gonna
fall apart Biden is falling apart and
that means that Bernie has basically
clear shot at the nomination and Bernie
has nobody standing in his way at this
point if he wins New Hampshire and right
now the polls show he's gonna win New
Hampshire walking away if he wins in New
Hampshire and then he shows up if he
wants Nevada this thing's over and
you've got an octogenarian socialist
loon bag whose staffs is who staffs
completely with people
who hate Israel and hate Jews that guy
is gonna be your nominee and it's
amazing because nobody's gonna ask him a
tough question and just take a look at
Bernie Sanders Twitter feed for a second
okay this is it's gonna be a
never-ending source of irritation to me
and nobody in the media will ask this
man a tough question about the fact that
he was a communist for most of his
career and is a communist today but then
hides it beneath absolute ridiculous
platitudes so take these kinds of tweets
right this one from just a few minutes
ago the idea is we are talking about a
livable planet health care is all right
a humane immigration system disability
justice a living wage for all and that
two radical ideas these are issues of
basic justice they're not ideas at all
they're nostrils they're phrases they
don't mean anything and this is Bernie's
routine it's so and one of the things
that you learn as a lawyer is you ask
people to define their terms my
definitions are really important because
words mean things and when people
obscure definitions what they are doing
is lying to you and Bernie despite all
of the talk about how honesty is not a
forthright he is bernie is a liar
because the fact is that bernie will not
explain to you what he means by anything
if you say Bernie what do you mean by
socialism he won't say I mean public
ownership of the means of production of
course I mean collectivization of major
industries that's not what he will say
to you he'll say well if by socialism
you mean that everybody should have a
living wage then I am a socialist okay
that is you're not even defining living
wage let alone how you achieve one take
capitalism achieves living wages if
capitalism didn't achieve living wages
you wouldn't have seen the greatest rise
in human prosperity in the history of
humanity by exponential scores like the
way you have since 1800 you wouldn't
have seen half the globe raised out of
abject poverty by free trade in
capitalism since 1980 you wouldn't see
any of that but Bernie says things like
I'm for a living wage that means I'm a
socialist no it just means that you're
not using words properly he says things
like I want the livable planet I guess
this makes me a socialist no you're
right Bernie everybody else wants a dead
planet everybody else wants to choke on
smog and die that's what we all want
because it is only socialist want a
livable planet the rest of us would
prefer a planet that is literally on
fire literally like where you just walk
around it's the end of Terminator 2
where everybody's just walking around on
fire and you're you're getting blow up
there you're fleshing blown off your
skeleton like come on health cut that's
all right okay that again
what do you mean by this that means
nothing the South African Constitution
guarantees healthcare is a right you
know doesn't have health care in South
Africa like everyone it guarantees
housing as a right you know doesn't have
a house in South Africa half the
population just saying something is
right does not mean that it materializes
he says he wants a humane immigration
said no you're right Bernie everybody
who opposes socialism is in favor of a
brutal immigration system in which we
treat people horribly like all of this
but this is Bernie shtick and no one
asks him what the hell you mean and
there's a reason no one asks and what
the hell it means there's a reason
because the minute that he gets down to
brass tacks everything turns ugly the
minute he gets down to brass tacks
everything gets really ugly there's a
perspective on the left and it is very
prominent that government is capable of
doing all of these things particularly
that government is capable of achieving
equality of outcome in a very root level
but the Constitution guarantees and was
supposed to guarantee and increasingly
did guarantee as it was fulfilled for
all citizens over time was equal
protection before the law what that
meant is that everyone was going to be
treated equally by the law hey that it
was not the job of government to
establish quote-unquote equality of
opportunity you know I know that
Republicans sometimes use equality of
opportunity but equality of opportunity
would encompass things like okay some
people grow up richer and some people
grow up poor obviously people who grow
up poor have different opportunities
than people who grow up rich so you have
to equalize these circumstances of birth
but that found the Constitution
guarantees the Constitution guarantees
equality before the law because you are
a human being with individual rights and
the government doesn't get to treat your
neighbor differently than the government
treats you right that is what the
government that that is what the
Constitution suggests the left suggests
a form of Rawls Ian John Rawls
philosopher from the mid twentieth
century Rawls E and social justice and
what that suggests is that we are
supposed to use government to achieve
equality of outcome how do we do this
well imagine here's the erosion
constructs and you eat Barack Obama used
to quote Rawls all the time the rauzein
construct is the idea that you don't
know how you're going to be born so
imagine that you're gonna be
reincarnated in any society but you
don't know what kind of society it is or
who you are going to be in that society
what kind of society would you hope was
was actually ruling right you don't know
they're gonna be rich or poor or smart
or stupid so what would you hope is the
society that would be that would be on
top well what would the government look
like so under those circumstances I
reject the premise
because that's not the way reality works
presumably everone would basically be a
Marxist right because if you're poor you
wish that you would be rich and if you
and maybe you'd be born rich but maybe
you wouldn't be and if you're
risk-averse you don't want to be the
person who is born poor maybe you're
born smart maybe you're born stupid the
idea is on the on behalf of folks on the
left that government is capable of
achieving these outcomes government is
not capable of achieving equality of
outcome it's just not
LBJ tried this in the mid-60s he ends up
with the greatest growth of governments
in the history of the United States and
he didn't end up lower in poverty in the
United States the percentage of people
living below the poverty line right now
is effectively the same as it was since
the beginning of the 70s so the the
notion that Bernie Sanders gonna come
along with governments and that he's
going to fix all problems basically his
plan goes like this
declare that socialism is insert thing
you want question mark utopia that's
Bernie Sanders's program and here's the
thing once he has to fill in those gaps
as it turns out to achieve equality of
outcome well you usually have to do is
kill a few people I mean is what
communism does it says in order to
achieve equality of outcome we're gonna
have to seize the property of a few
people if they don't like it then we're
gonna have to imprison them we're going
to have to restrict them from moving
we're going to have to crack down on
individual rights we're going to have to
redistribute everything eventually what
we're really gonna need to do is just
collectivise the ownership make it
government owned so we can redistribute
the proceeds we're gonna need to do that
at the very least okay that ends up
pretty ugly and this is why when
Elizabeth Warren tried to fill in the
gaps on Bernie Sanders on even basic
things that he's proposing like Medicare
for all she got destroyed because
burning will say Medicare for all and
people say so what's your plan for this
and what does it look like and Bernie
will just say things like well it will
cost you us well no it won't but he
doesn't ever actually roll out his plan
right he'll just promise you the moon
and then when you say hey how're you
gonna get to the moon and he just
refuses to answer the question then this
is a sign of genius Elizabeth Warren the
problem for her is she would promise you
the moon and then we'd say okay so how
are we gonna have to get to the moon and
say well what we're gonna need to do is
we're going to need to take you and phew
and load you as fuel into this rocket
it's gonna be bad for you it's been
great for everybody else in America so
that sounds kind of bad the minute you
put any flesh on the bones of Bernie's
ridiculous Nostrum his agenda completely
collapses which is why the media don't
bother to actually vote any flesh under
the skeleton
all of his campaigns are like this if he
watches if he watches rallies if you
look at his Twitter I mean stuff like
this right if you feel like a political
system doesn't work for you now is the
time to join in our fight together we
are going to end the corruption of a
system that helps billionaires believes
working people behind we are going to
build a government that represents all
of us what the hell are you talking
about this is all empty rhetoric it
doesn't mean anything what is your
actual plan what is your actual plan and
the answer is he doesn't have an actual
plan he just has a bunch of nonsensical
garbage that he tosses out there for the
for the pleasure of idiots who think
that simply expressing a wish makes it
more plausible that it will come true
and you never have to connect the wish
with the reality at any point at some
point this reality will have to set in
for Bernie I mean at some point he will
be asked these tough questions but
apparently he's gonna be able to float
right through the primaries without
anybody asking those tough questions why
because the Democratic Party decided to
suck off the teat of Bernie Sanders his
socialist energy and now it's too late
now it's too late the blood stream has
been poisoned Bernie Sanders you can't
adopt half of Bernie Sanders his plans
and then rip on Bernie Sanders his
general ideology which is what Joe Biden
basically has tried to do you can't do
that it's bound to fail and that's why
Bernie is in very good position moving
forward and Democrats are in sheer panic
and they should be in sheer panic okay
time for a couple of things I like and
then we'll get to a thing that I hate so
things that I like today so very sad
Kirk Douglas passed away yesterday is
103 years old so that always sort of
mitigates the sadness to these sent that
if you live to 103 that's a pretty long
and good life
Kirk Douglas of course one of the
biggest stars in Hollywood from
basically the 50s through the through
the late 60s he had a solid 20-year run
as one of the biggest stars in Hollywood
and made a bunch of just fantastic
movies right Spartacus is a great movie
I'm a huge fan of the gunfight at the OK
Corral really underrated flick and and I
think his best movie what many people
believe is his best performance is the
movie ace in the hole which is which is
a movie about a story that was really
big at the time in there there was even
a novel by Robert Penn Warren that was
written about this the Pulitzer Prize
winner and the movie ace in the hole is
about a journalist a really corrupt it's
a it's such a cynical hard-boiled movie
it's about a cynical and corrupt
journalist who is covering the story
of a man who is trapped underground in a
mineshaft collapse and about how he
blows up the story and people are
arriving and rooting for the guy and
he's lying to the public about it in
order so that he can is said he can
achieve some sort of greater measure of
Fame it's a really brutal hard-boiled
movie here it is ace in the hole
phony below the belt journalism that's
what it is
not below that though right in the gut
mr. Putin human interest nothing you've
ever seen before has the tremendous
human interest of ace in the hole for
here is a startling story of human
emotions and human desires played
against the most exciting fight to save
a man's life ever depicted on the screen
now in small it comes you can give them
yours tell them they're going through
the cliff dwelling shored up and get him
out fast now through the cliff dwelling
you can't get them out that way anymore
[Music]
Billy Wilder and Billy Wilder of course
one of the great directors in Hollywood
history actually produced directed and
wrote this one it's it's a really
fantastic movie and an absolutely true
ticket if you haven't seen richard
juliet the new Clint Eastwood movie this
is basically a very early version of
Richard rule about how journalists suck
and it is it is accurate Kirk Douglas is
an actor who played mean a lot sort of
like William Holden in his early days
and he was he was magnetic on-screen I
mean he's terrific and Spartacus
underrated as an actor because he's a
movie star more than he is an actor but
nason the whole use of some actual
acting was not afraid to play nasty on
screen of course his son Michael Douglas
survives him and and so you know prayers
for the for the family of Kirk Douglas I
saw some people last night who are
passing around old accusations that were
sort of rumors that had never been
corroborated about him and Natalie Wood
that he had allegedly raped Natalie Wood
that was those trending on Twitter last
night it seems to me that if you're
going to make an allegation that you
ought to of that sort that you ought to
back it up more than just to have that
trend on Twitter on the day that the man
dies at 103 years old he was alive until
yesterday if you wanted to make that an
issue perhaps you should have perhaps
you should have made that an issue a lot
earlier it seems rather cynical to do it
on the day the demand dies okay time for
well actually another quick thing that I
like so I do love when when folks on the
left to take things incredibly literally
they take like they have no sense of
humor they have no unfocus on the hard
left I'm talking about like you'll see
people on the Left will get very upset
because we have this left is tears
tumblr as though it is not number one
semi ironic and number two as though it
does not make the distinction between
leftist and liberal so you'll get very
mad about this oh no why are you so
brutal the leftist tears aren't you just
playing on fears no if you don't get the
joke you don't get the joke and I can't
explain the joke to you but left us do
this routinely they sort of take things
incredibly literal so so listen to AOC
taking incredibly literally the the
phrase that you're supposed to pull
yourself up by your own bootstraps that
is just it's it's an idiom it's an idiom
a lot of idioms don't make physical
sense have-your-cake- and-eat-it-too
what the hell is that supposed to mean
but here's aoc explaining that because
the idiom lift yourself up by your own
bootstraps doesn't actually make
physical sense therefore as an idea that
you should actually work hard on your
own to overcome your obstacles therefore
that doesn't hold true either which of
course this is galaxy brainstuff from
AOC Hutchinson I was want to thank you
about bringing up the poverty draft and
this idea of a bootstrap you know this
idea and this metaphor of a bootstrap
started off as a joke because it's a
physical impossibility to lift yourself
up by a bootstrap by your shoelaces it's
physically impossible the whole thing is
a joke Thank You AOC for explaining you
cannot physically lift yourself up by
your own bootstraps because they are
connected to your feet and that's not
the way that force and physics work yes
we got all of that thank you
galaxy brain AOC for explaining the
basic idioms don't necessarily make
sense
Wow I you know you've changed my opinion
now I am a Marxist now I'm a Marxist
because that phrase doesn't make sense
on its own you're exactly right now this
means that we have to redistribute all
income an American society excellent
excellent point
AOC unbelievable okay time for a quick
thing that I hate so the New York Human
Rights Commission has gone completely
insane peace by Robbie suave over at
reason calm the New York Commission on
Human Rights an oversight agency that
monitors compliance with the city's
incredibly broad anti-discrimination law
has now ordered the fashion company
Prada to stop selling certain toy dolls
described by many as racist caricatures
akin to blackface and send its employees
to sensitivity training hey this is
supposedly in a free country the New
York City Commission on Human Rights is
now ordering people what they can and
cannot sell on the basis of restriction
of speech in doing so the overzealous
agency is claiming a vast new powers to
police a private entities behavior
unfortunately Prada is meekly submitting
to the commission's demands and other
companies including Dior and Gucci are
facing similar inquisitions which of
course is not any sort of shock because
the bad publicity associated with the
New York Commission on Human Rights
going after you is not worth the profit
to be made from selling trinkets in
September the Commission announced that
an employer or landlords use of the term
illegal alien could be considered a form
of illegal discrimination and results in
a fine of up to 250 thousand dollars the
sweeping declaration was made without
any reference to oft-cited limitations
hostile speech must generally be severe
pervasive pervasive and objectively
offensive to rise to the level of
harassment for example there is no
that meets with First Amendment approval
but this is what the New York City
Commission on Human Rights is it I mean
that they've suggested that if somebody
comes into your bar and they're
transsexual or transgender person and
that if you call them by their the
biological pronoun
maybe you should be fined a quarter
million dollars does that really accord
with your vision of the First Amendment
if it does let me suggest you're getting
the First Amendment completely
completely wrong even before the
declaration the Commission had begun an
investigation into Prada after receiving
complaints that some of their
merchandise was racially insensitive
according to the New York Times for the
last year the New York Commission on
Human Rights who was enforcement agency
of the municipal government charged with
overseeing the city's Human Rights laws
as they apply to housing retail
establishments and other areas has been
investigating and in settlement talks
with Prada a process culminating in a
deal signed on February 4th just in
times to set nerves on edge during
fashion month so the Commission sent
Prada a cease and desist letter after a
member of the Commission saw a New
Yorkers angry social media post about
the doll this New Yorker genera easy a
civil rights attorney filed a complaint
with Commission last January so proud a
signed an agreement with the Commission
the company will not force all of its
employees and company executives in
Milan Italy through racial sensitivity
training then they will appoint a
diversity and inclusion officer subject
to the Commission's approval so the
Commission now gets to hire people over
at products unbelievable this person
will be tasked with quote reviewing the
Pradas designs before they are sold
advertised or promoted in any way in the
United States because this is just the
government taking over product
development to Prada and proud of going
along with it because in order for them
to operate without legal liability in
the city of New York they're just going
to let this person greenlight all
projects appropriate for the city of New
York I mean this is tyranny it really is
it really is and you could see this
easily happening with regard to any
variety of products in New York City
let's say that they decide that the New
York Post let's say the New York Post
uses the term illegal alien and the New
York City Human Rights Commission
decides the term illegal alien is in and
of itself discriminatory order the New
York Post decides to call people by
their biological pronouns and the Human
Rights Commission says you're not
allowed to do that and if you do do that
then your distribution of the newspaper
every single day will be punishable by a
$250,000 fine so here's what we're gonna
do we're going to appoint a person to
the board of the New York Post and that
person is going to be an editor who is
going to go through and check all of
your content for discriminatory Khan
and that's how we are going to
effectuate a hate free New York would
that be a violation of freedom of speech
you bet your ass would be a violation of
freedom of speech and it would be
tyranny the government overtly cracking
down on freedom of speech that's no
different just because you're selling
the product hey also product is required
to tell the Commission the demographic
makeup of its staff at every level and
summarize pratas past and future
activities aimed at increasing the
number of people from protected classes
underrepresented in the fashion industry
so they're now going to shot decide on
the staffing company wide based on
quotas so in New York City with its non
elected Human Rights Commission's I
don't believe these are elected
positions I believe they're appointed by
the mayor these people are going to
decide for Prada how to staff their
entire company their entire company if
you are a you now locate your
business in New York City you wonder why
people are rushing out of New York City
to Florida this is why people are
rushing out of New York City to Florida
Gucci has already announced they're
going to do this sort of thing as Robbie
suave points out in short government
bureaucrats have decided that existing
anti-discrimination law gives them the
power to tell fashion companies what
sort of merchandise they can sell this
is explicitly power they've claimed for
themselves deputy commissioner Sapna Raj
made this clear to the New York Times
saying quote I don't know that we
realized previously so many major
fashion houses had the ignorance of the
race history of racism in this country
we hope companies realize they need to
be very careful about how they market
and advertise that they need to have a
larger social and cultural consciousness
okay if this doesn't scare the hell out
of you it's because you don't understand
what free speech was supposed to be it's
so funny there are people on the Left
will say things like cancel culture
doesn't exist
you're literally cramming down the
ability to cancel an entire company
based on the size of the fines
so long as you do not approve of their
staffing decisions and product and
marketing decisions that's not freedom
that's not freedom in any way shape or
form but this is the world in their nose
the all these memes out there this is
the world the left ones this is the
world left ones if the Left had its way
they would be appointing a couple more
justices to the Supreme Court so that
any legal challenge to this sort of
thing would be knocked down and then the
Democrats on a national level
would be pushing for pushing for hate
speech legislation we're five minutes
away from this it already exists in
Britain in our existing Canada with dire
effects so when when the left tells you
they're for personal freedom just remind
them that personal freedom apparently
doesn't extends the ability to market or
say the things that you want to market
or say so long
you live in New York City unbelievable
stuff already we would back here later
today with two additional hours of
content for you otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel lie
down scoop technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2025 president Trump has
officially been acquitted in the
Senate's farce impeachment trial but not
before snake-in-the-grass Mitt Romney
gets in one last little nip before being
relegated to ignominy and obscurity we
will compare sanctimonious backstabbers
with serious and successful
conservatives then the Trump
administration leaks a draft of possibly
the single most important executive
order we will see in our lifetimes to
make America beautiful again finally
Andrew yang reminds us why the left no
matter how wacky should never be trusted
all that in the mailbag check it out on
the Michael nose
you
[Music]